a banda
[Música]
boa noite 12 todas eu queria começar
hoje fazendo uma pergunta eu me
perguntar quem vocês são hoje como foi a
sua história e como será o seu futuro
essas são algumas perguntas que eu tenho
feito algum tempo
hoje eu vou subir algo que me deixa
muito desconfortável
hoje eu gosto de mim
hoje vou falar e poder ser escutado
hoje nossa história
eu estava na escola fundamental
o assunto alguns conhecem como se
acumulando e da gasolina e laborais
eu morava nos fundos da casa da minha
avó e meu pai minha mãe meu irmão
os meus pais levantaram a vida inteira
da educação e os maiores orgulhos
cristinho é falar que eu me mandar um
escola particular
mesmo quando isso se refletia em todo o
investimento da casa de dinheiro que
pude viagens passeios brinquedos jogos
tudo ainda é o dinheiro da comida
diferente ali ou da reforma da casa
tudo investido tivesse uma história
particular oportunidade minha família
nunca teve
mesmo assim continuava sendo um
sacrifício
a idéia da escola é empréstimo até
empréstimo é pedido de bolsa a taxa de
bolsas em todo semelhante renegociar as
dívidas com escola até às vezes minha
mãe teve seu parecer que trabalha na
escola para me manter lá nós mas fazendo
questão de deixar claro o quanto ele
sabe disso e militar para a família o
quanto é importante pra gente
hoje reconheço todo o amor que tinha o
foco do investimento mas não tinha toda
a sensibilidade da isso ainda
e depois quando foi à escola
eu percebi que eu tinha muitas
dificuldades de defesa não conseguia ter
a simplicidade dos pais e mais forte em
outros desafios mas não é só pelo bem
das notas baixas ou às vezes você é
aquele menino magrinho e baixinho de
impulso do mundo como dizem na classe
muitas vezes o motivo da piada era minha
roupa mas vai ser preciso respeitar um
pouco a situação da escola de outros
alunos
então ele estava como ter um pouco mais
do tipo van gogh um pouco mais amarelada
advogado lugar
eu chegava à escola e alguns amigos
perguntavam nossas homem lavava a roupa
não adianta botar uma roupa nova
nesse momento eu me escondi a minha
vergonha mas quando estava com a roupa
nova e é na escola e chegar na escola
que sorriso no rosto e até da coragem de
levantar noiva de pergunta a professora
outras vezes o motivo da piada era o meu
sapato já velho de mais sujo demais ou
seja uma marca que ninguém conhecia
eu lembro de uma vez em quando é de um
campeonato de futebol da escola do
título nacional pode levar pela chuteira
chega na loja eu já sabia mais ou menos
enquanto a gente puder parcelar e olho
na virgin e um sapato assim dourado
ele chega época de pedras coloridas
ainda não tinha nenhum pedido de dorival
pegar bebida a secretaria de cachoeira
dourada em maca chuteiras assim eu
coloquei tão boa
desde que eu tinha de ser campeão mas
comprou depois no dia da final do seu
pessoal o meu pai levado neste jogo
chega do rádio longe pessoal da mídia
chegando né também construirá dourada né
e ainda nesse dia eu tive quando se
aproximou e lhe perguntado ele tinha que
marca que é a minha resposta pouco
importava que na verdade era o início de
um tipo de piada alguma dessas situações
compartilhar com os pais e outras não
quando como eu queria levar um lanche da
escola ou comprar um lanche no intervalo
eu falei pra todo mundo leva muitas
moedas após ler alguma coisa também por
lá ea gente a possibilidade de existir
para tomar um café da manhã reforçado
assim montar o mesmo chocolate que tinha
mas acho que nem pela roupa nova pelos
sapatos de marca ou pelo twitter logo eu
acho que eu queria me sentir incluso
ele sente lá no dia que passa um tanto
em mim mais uma sala de aula manter
amizades
era muito difícil afinal eu dava
disfunções e muitas das cheias de
adversário
nas idas ao cinema o batom espaço tinha
suas limitações e é um papa no dia a dia
o tempo passou ea de sentimento por dias
melhores
foi crescendo e eu decidi que queria
fazer na verdade pública ou melhor a
minha opção é baseado na cidade
então eu comecei a trabalhar na zona
oeste no telemarketing
wilsinho centro de são paulo eo do dia
do total projetado nos nossos dias a
viagem de dois anos
em uma dessas viagens quando eu saí de
telemarketing - sim eu pensava quando
esse período difícil no baixo e eu
passei na frente da banca de jornal
ainda no jornal titula revista assim que
falava jovem empreendedor de 20 anos já
tem carro casa chega próximo do primeiro
milhão
eu parei de fazer tanto melhor
depois de muitas batalhas causa da crise
eu passei uma unidade pública vai na usc
curso não muito concorrida na faculdade
é sempre uma questão né
passaram a gostar de passar na verdade
pouco mas a fia deixa claro que para
quem pensa que está aqui uns em defesa
da advocacia entrou entrar e aproveitar
a deixa claro o quanto esta jornada
deixou marcas em mim e na minha saúde
mental
nesse caminho e fez de barreiras e vive
invisíveis que não é tão fácil de
enxergar produção da pele tudo meus
amigos meus e amigas deixaram barreiras
culturais que eu iniciei um progênio
como raça eu tenho pra mim que só deu
certo o apoio do meu pai e da minha mãe
o irmão da namorada
isso é fundamental ter sucesso na
faculdade acredita que todo mundo podia
é obra sei espaço
algumas me ajuda a aprofundar um caos
total a equipe vem aprofundando na um
trabalho sócio ambiental até que eu
comecei a trabalhar em uma das ligações
que eu mais admirava em 2015
ontem na tunísia com esse apoio ao
negócio de impacto social e os projetos
que eu toco lá é aceleradora de negócios
impacto o bebê teria chorado muito legal
e bom as coisas estavam caminhando né
estava formado um trabalho que está
muito próximo
meu irmão também estava empregado
a gente já tinha começado a atacar as
dicas valem a formação inicial quando
tinha terminado a faculdade mas eu não
sabia muito bem que pensar num sabe dos
meus clientes vão falar sobre o futuro
e eu só tinha sonhado até bin foi
reformado e emprego que você espera
sonhar e resolveu começar a olhar um
pouco mais sobre esse processo
nessa jornada
eu mesmo falei com algumas pessoas uma
delas o chef felipe
eu cheguei pra ele uma pergunta bastante
abertas
é como quais são as possibilidades pra
onde o de fazer um encontro dessa coisa
assim
o próximo passo né ele percebendo o
quanto estava aberta às duas perguntas
perguntava o que você mais gosta de
fazer ressurgir dia né
o que mais motiva ia fazer aquela coisa
né gente esperta né
ele me perguntou parece incrível que eu
sonho
no sonho
na hora só consegui pensar em coisas que
não vai ser muito boa para qualquer um
mas mesmo envergonhado disse
era meu sonho é mais uma viagem para a
madeira e família
esse é meu sonho é verdade eu sou um
legítimo do dia até hoje mas eu percebi
que realmente se olhar para as coisas
que talvez um pouco mais pra mim então
resolvi tomar uma jornada de olhar cada
vez mais para mim porque eu estava
trabalhando na área socioambiental
sob o olhar da pm vitor do cursinho
ensino médio da infância e que tinha lá
atrás dessas conversas
eu lembrei de uma feira uma pessoa e e
nessa cena eu estava num dia de trabalho
ea gente discutir sobre iniciativas de
impacto social
o tema da mobilidade saúde e uma das
iniciativas e me peguei a ela e eu
comecei a entender eu falo mesmo assim
bom gente
em geral a população de baixa renda
quando você pegar um medicamento insumos
de saúde se não tenha culpa pra casa ela
vai e volta do dia esse processo vai
gastando dinheiro deu sorte né
esse pensar se você for uma pessoa idosa
ou com dificuldade de mobilidade
na hora eu senti uma coisa estranha mas
também possibilitar o que era quando
lembrei dessa cena naquela reunião
eu percebi que quando falava da
população de baixa renda
eu pensava na minha avó
eu percebi que quando eu falava da
periferia
eu pensava no meu dia a dia eu tenho
feito contado a minha própria história
na terceira pessoa
depois dali é pra ajudar um pouco a
entendeu como estava com 100
eu sou meio bicho bb no final do x um
texto pronto escrito assim é uma carta
de mim time mesmo com tanta história
resolvi compartilhar a internet facebook
10 35 segundo celular só teve que cortar
é e foi um processo bastante
interessante
algumas pessoas vieram e me trouxeram o
bando identificado como o aposentado ali
e outras pessoas que estavam comigo ou
que tava trabalhando comigo no dia a dia
e já um cara como eu sabia de nada disso
a gente estudou tanto tempo juntos vamos
abrir
daí em diante já passaram e algumas
outras queixas foram caindo eu comecei a
perceber o quanto estava focado na minha
rotina objetivos
eu estou em pé de mim eu já não sabia
mais que eu trabalhe e por que o brasil
fazia eu percebi que eu não falava de
mim e do meu bebê
eu consegui esconder e cuja minha
própria realidade da minha história
ao longo da vida eu estudei está em
espaços não me sentia atraente e usava
uma máscara eu nem sabia que usava para
continuar com essas pastas
[Música]
eu acho que a conversa com pessoas que
vêm de outras trajetórias me ajudaram
muito a cada vez mais sobre mim mesmo
assim eu esteja ainda muito no processo
de dúvidas incertezas e medos e
aprendizados
mas eu descobri porque pra começar a
olhar para o futuro com qualidade
você começa a olhar para o passado 1
sabedoria não sentindo me utilizar
mas sim editar fortalecer e que acima de
tudo está muito tempo sobre a forma como
o bloco 1
afinal de contas você começa a contar
sua própria história na terceira pessoa
é sinal de vocês leitoras avaí
[Música]